voilà bien alors vous savez mont saint
michel que notre émission va un peu
partout dans le monde francophone et
variés comme vous avez l'art d'imiter un
petit peu de prendre tous les accents je
vous demande et de saluer car avec un
décalage cette émission va arriver à
noël après noël peut être après le 1er
janvier vous êtes donc souhaiter un bon
noël et un bon 1er janvier bonnes fêtes
de fin d'année on va commencer par les
belges puisqu'ils sont les plus proches
de nous ils nous reçoivent également sûr
j'aimerais si c'est possible m'adresser
à tous nos amis belges
ce serait si sympathique une fois et
surtout leur dire que comme ma grand
mère était belge parce qu'elle avait une
pizza cacher à bruxelles qui marchait
très bien oui et j'étais petite rue des
bouchers je vous embrasse tous sur
toutes vos bouches
je suis déçu alors maintenant label'vie
beau noël au suisse oui mais alors là
pour les suisses le seul problème c'est
que on a tellement peu de temps dans
l'émission pour leur souhaiter un joyeux
noël
parce qu'il parle quand même pas très
très vite alors faudra faire une autre
émission pour rien on souhaite un bon
noël est un mauvais oeil aux allemands
carrière et en ouvre une zone proche
carton et en étant malade afrique du
nord
la tunisie nous sommes reçues en tunisie
en algérie au maroc est très content
l'inde est aussi éloigné les arbres de
noël déguisés les boules partout à tout
autant à toi ça va bien mais là si on
redescend maintenant on va vers
l'afrique noire celle que vous
connaissez bien oui si vous devez à tout
ça mais je voudrais vous souhaiter à
tous un grand jouet noël même s'il n'y a
pas d'arbres de sapin mais de palmer et
je voudrais vous dire que vous avez de
la chance de par michel drucker en
couleur et noir et blanc
il n'est pas impossible qu'un jour par
satellite sans elysées à y encore
beaucoup plus loin au japon en chine au
pays du soleil levant
alors oui c'est bien vrai